corona in afrika wir wollen wissen was
das virus mit einem land wie der
zentralafrikanischen republik macht und
wie die menschen dort damit umgehen
es ist eine spurensuche tief im herzen
des kontinents aus der
zentralafrikanischen republik dringen
nur selten nachrichten nach außen das
land zählt zu den drei ärmsten der welt
unsere reise beginnt in der provinzstadt
bus m billy genauer an einem kühlschrank
des bezirkskrankenhauses
dort sind 22 dosen impfstoff
eingetroffen ihre wenig für den ort mit
20.000 einwohnern
woher kommt der impfstoff aus der
hauptstadt banken und was ist das für
ein impfstoff
astrazeneca
endlich ist er also da der rohstoff aus
dem reichen norden
vorm krankenhaus warten schon zahlreiche
menschen auf die impfung die meisten
sind mitarbeiter des hospitals
zum beispiel die krankenschwester julia
don pooley die seit wochen auf diesen
tag gewartet hat
bisher tut es nicht mal sehen wie es
später aussieht
bei den meisten hier macht sich grosse
erleichterung breit nach der spritze ich
habe schon leute sterben sehen ankurbelt
diese krankheit ist realität
es ist ein glückstag für gerade mal 22
menschen die anderen müssen weiter
warten es kann wochen dauern bis zur
nächsten lieferung
am krankenhaus von boss mb arbeitet
gerade eine deutsche ärztin für ein
halbes jahr mit heike dannenberg hilft
heute beim impfen ihr alltag hier ist
allerdings vom kampf gegen andere
krankheiten geprägt
das durchschnittsalter der bevölkerung
ist ja auch anders sondern sich an die
menschen die ankunft werden was für ein
alter die haben
vielleicht ein problem was hier gar
nicht in der in dem maße existieren
corona also nicht das größte problem am
krankenhaus von billy die malaria bietet
in der region acre dannenberg kämpft
gerade um das leben eines drei monate
alten säuglings mit hohem fieber und
schweren krämpfen die diagnostischen und
therapeutischen mittel sind begrenzt die
ärztin kommt hier manchmal an ihre
grenzen
in berlin
ich bin ja noch nicht mal
die menschen haben andere sorgen die
ihnen größer erscheinen als corona die
sicherheitslage sie ist fragil in
mozambique anfang des jahres drangen
rebellen aus dem norden in den ort ein
sie hinterließen eine spur der
verwüstung
viele einwohner mussten fliehen die
familie
während ihre bällen hier wüteten hatte
die familie in der wildnis aus
wochen lang
es war schrecklich dort erlebt nicht
ständiger angst vor wilden tieren und
schlangen die uns reißen könnten
ein paar wochen später als die regierung
wieder das gebiet kontrollierte
kehrte die familie zurück doch fast ihr
gesamtes habe ist jetzt weg sogar das
bett haben zu uns gestohlen
schlimmer noch dass bartoli konnte sein
man york fällt nicht bestellen es ist
zugewuchert mit unkraut in den nächsten
monaten wird es schwer die familie zu
ernähren und wer weiß ob die rebellen
nicht wiederkommen
die nahmen auch aus dem rathaus alles
mit was nicht niet und nagelfest war
eine funktionierende verwaltung gibt es
seitdem nicht mehr die distrikt chefin
hat nicht mal einen computer
leider wurden unsere büros komplett
zerstört so dass die beamten nun alle zu
hause sitzen es gibt keine schreibtische
mehr kein schreibmaterial wir haben
nichts mehr kein ort ein renovierungs
zusammensetzen könnten
das ist gerade unser problem
wir fahren in die hauptstadt bank die
auch dort ist die sicherheitslage
äußerst unstabil denn in der
zentralafrikanischen republik tobt seit
jahren ein von der welt fast vergessene
bürgerkrieg
als schutzmacht hat sich frankreich aus
seiner früheren kolonie weitgehend
zurückgezogen
die blauhelme aus ruanda und bangladesch
sind kaum in der lage sicherheit zu
garantieren
seit einiger zeit sorgen russische
soldaten aber auch seltener in teilen
des landes für eine gewisse ordnung von
der regierung begrüßt in der bevölkerung
befürchtet wegen ihrer brutalität
auch beim filmen müssen wir aufpassen
immer wieder gibt es checkpoints wer
gerade wo das sagen hat schwer zu
durchschauen
kein wunder dass unter diesen umständen
corona nicht die höchste priorität im
land hat und da der impfstoff ohnehin
knapp ist bleiben die ziele der
regierung erst einmal bescheiden in
einem land in dem die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung mit 53 jahren die
niedrigste der welt ist
wir impfen jetzt die priorität gruppe 1
das sind bei uns vor allem die menschen
die 50 jahre und älter sind
in afrika sind noch nicht einmal zwei
prozent der menschen vollständig geimpft
das dürfte noch folgen für die ganze
welt haben schließlich könnten neue
gefährliche varianten entstehen dabei
könnte selbst ein armes land wie die
zentralafrikanische republik wohl recht
schnell eine höhere quote erreichen wenn
nur genügend impfstoff da wäre
wir haben in allen programmen lücken
immer geschlossene dem wir selbst
impfstoffe gekauft haben das ist
normalerweise auch möglichen wir jetzt
ist es nicht möglich weil es gibt kein
corona in stoff die problematik ist auf
der ganzen welt bekannt wir werden
bereit im land ja gibt's gute impf teams
es gab eine große kinderlähmung kampagne
bis vor zwei jahren also diese teams
sind alle bereit
es ist nichts da
für das gesamte land gab es bislang
gerade mal 100 1000 impfdosen aus dem
internationalen kovacs programm auch
deshalb fordert der korona beauftragte
die freigabe der impf patente
das wäre sehr nützlich das wissen sollte
allen ländern und auch der bevölkerung
zentralafrikas zugänglich sein
wir fahren weiter in das kleine dorf wo
song go im südwesten des landes auch
hier haben die meisten einwohner schon
von corona gehört aber menschen die die
gefahr nicht ernst nehmen die gibt es
auch hier
cobit existiert man diese frau aber
jesus ist stärker
auch hier stellen wir fest die menschen
haben andere existenzielle sorgen neben
corona
sauberes trinkwasser etwa und nahrung
die hälfte der zentralafrikaner hat
nicht genug zu essen solange diese
probleme nicht gelöst sind spielt corona
nur eine nebenrolle
auch der pfarrer des dorfes wiegelt ab
als wir nach dem chor ohne probleme in
seiner gemeinde frage wir hatten noch
keinen einzigen fall
die lehrerin der dorfschule aber hält
corona für eine große gefahr und fordert
solidarität von der internationalen
gemeinschaft
was denken sie über die impfungen halten
sie das für gerecht dass in europa 60
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sind und
in afrika vielleicht gerade mal
24 hat man von impfung noch gar nichts
gesehen niemand hilft uns es wäre
wichtig dass endlich impfstoff hier
ankommen damit wir besser geschützt
werden
die leute haben wirklich richtig angst
zahlreiche infektionen dürften nie
entdeckt werden weil kaum getestet wird
ein labor gibt es nämlich nur in der
hauptstadt
die offiziellen zahlen bisher 11.000
infizierte und 100 tote dürften nur
geringe aussagekraft haben
dass das virus hier umgeht musste sarah
schütz am eigenen leib erfahren die
27-jährige ist für neun monate als
hebamme am krankenhaus von boss mb unter
einfachsten bedingungen hilft sie hier
kinder auf die welt zu bringen und
irgendwie hat sie sich das corona virus
eingefangen und erkrankte daran obwohl
sie bereits doppelt geimpft war ich
hatte eigentlich das gefühl das ist so
eine erkältung ist weil irgendwie viel
arbeit und einfach fertige stress und
einfach mal ein bisschen ausschlafen
also ich hatte auch so schnupfen und
kratzen dann bin ich nach bunny in die
quarantäne
und
genau da hat es dann auch tatsächlich
angefangen dass ich nichts mehr
geschmeckt habe und nichts mehr
gebrochen hat bzw ganz ganz wenig
sarah schütz hat sich gut erholt sie
widmet sich nun wieder einheimischen
frauen die probleme während der
schwangerschaft haben malaria etwa führt
oft zu frühgeburten an corona denkt sie
kaum noch wie die meisten menschen in
zentralafrika die mit hunger bürgerkrieg
und oft todbringenden tropenkrankheiten
zu kämpfen haben
in diesem fragilen staat im herzen
afrikas ist corona für viele ein
weiteres problem im täglichen
überlebenskampf
nicht mehr und nicht weniger
[Musik]